drag the lines up or down order them
from longest to shortest put the longest
line on top
sorry out of these three lines the
longest one is this one so i click on
this and i move it to the top
and they want us to order from longest
to shortest so we want the longest on
top and the shortest on the bottom and
the medium one in the middle and that's
what we have longest less long and the
the least long or the shortest right
over there let's keep going
all right
is it taller or shorter
so let's see this whale even if we don't
count the water that's coming out of its
spout is taller than these three blocks
so i would say the whale is
taller than
three blocks if i said the whale is
shorter than three blocks it wouldn't
make sense because a whale is more than
three blocks tall
so it's taller than the three box
the squirrel is well the squirrel is
clearly shorter than the three blocks it
looks like it's about two blocks tall so
the squirrel is shorter than the two
blocks we scroll down because it's
another question
so the whale is blank the squirrel
well the whale's going to be taller than
the squirrel and you could see that if
you just compare compare the whale
straight to the squirrel or you can say
look if the whale is more than three
blocks the whale is taller than three
blocks the squirrel is shorter than
three blocks so the whale must be taller
than the squirrel because the whale is
taller than the blocks which are taller
than the squirrel so the whale is going
to be taller than the squirrel let's
keep going
is it taller or shorter
the cookie is shorter than these five
blocks
the ice cream cone is well looks it's
taller than the five box
so the cookie is well the cookie is
shorter than the five blocks which is
shorter than the ice cream cone the ice
cream cone is taller than the blocks
which are taller than the cookie so the
cookie is for sure shorter than the ice
cream cone it's shorter than this which
is shorter than the ice cream cone so
it's definitely shorter than the ice
cream cone let's do one more
is it taller or shorter well the penguin
is taller than the four blocks the
turtle is shorter than the ten blocks
but then that's right then the four
blocks the penguin is taller than four
blocks the turtle is shorter than four
blocks so the penguin is what's going to
be taller than the turtle the penguin is
taller than the blocks which are taller
than the turtle so the penguin is taller
than the turtle lots of fun